Even if Tazoe was beaten by Shinyu, those who are driven by emotion are not suitable for
snipers.A good sniper is someone who has a strong interest in chasing and killing things before cold-blooded.
I can't even move forward
3 and I'm sure you know the intimidation of a beautiful door
If it's me, oh
I'll be the man who sniped Ria
Find the traces of the sleigh that fled into the law and
pursue it, sniping it with two parts of the target's care and sniping
around the side  From this position, I can't see where I hit
from on the slope.
But there's no way it's going to show
up like a guilt It's like a match with a
rough metal stick It's inserted into a chemical and it ignites when you lift your luggage
Maybe it's the man of the hour
, but I should have hit
it I paid tribute to his courage to
save his comrades at the cost of his life.
I'm the sniper who decides
I'm not the kind of guy who comes out to help
A human love star who doesn't mind hearing moans all night long
[music]